[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah ah
ok
[Musique]
une partenaire ok ah non c'est pas un
tennis de test
ah non c'est pas
on va chez vous actuellement
oui
face à ce constat
pourquoi ça oui
ok ouais
[Musique]
il
d'abord
ouais
bonsoir bonsoir moi j'avais quelque
chose de spécial ben je sais pas qu'est
ce que vous faites est ce que vous
proposez ou parce qu'on propose c'est
variable ça dépend de tout le monde
on cherche déjà un coucou soit jeune et
sympa vous avez l'air
pourquoi
tu vois je
à ce moment là ce qu'on fait bon salaire
de coller
la femme
allez comme ça ça va aller
des trucs marrants soan est chaud a bien
sûr déjà comme ça et basse le rapport à
ce qu'on fait c'est que les
néo vous emmène on va où on va chez vous
on va tirer mieux chez nous voyons des
pauvres après ici
wayne tellement on monte un truc tous
les cadeaux comment la whey il ya
d'autres gens qui gagnent donc
éventuellement la dent à [__] qui va
peut-être venir montferrier rien de sûr
quand vous voulez vous on attend un
petit peu ou alors on y va tous les
quatre on y va tous les quatre
[Musique]
converse
forcément
c'est exactement
faye a prévu
aimargues
mark harris bonsoir vous avez tourné ça
quand on a tourné sa avant-hier lancé
embusqués avec une petite copine porte
dauphine ouais c'était mardi au début et
puis
et puis on sait on a tourné la tournée
comme tous les gens qui tournent leurs
dauphines et puis ça a été un peu
bizarre parce que moi je connaissais pas
je dois dire ouais et on a rencontré des
coupes rempiler béatrice nicolas n'est
pas là et souhaite marier tous les deux
et vous essayez de dire aux gens vous
êtes mariés il ya trois mois trois mois
quand vous n'êtes pas perdu de temps non
non on se connaît depuis sept ans comme
un bon d'accord mais au présent 13 ans
est marié vous avez commencé à faire ça
quand même temps après votre mariage aux
fans ou ce différend oui pourquoi parce
que bon ce qu'on vient de voir c'est pas
tout à fait notre approche ah bon c'est
quoi votre approche et nous nous sommes
plutôt organisateurs avant
privé en privé ça c'est du public oui
mais vous faites à quatre ou à plusieurs
après non nous quand on organise on
n'organise pas pour pour deux couples
ont organisé pour
au minimum 20 30 40 faire qu'on se
retrouve deux fois 80 personnes 80
personnes sachez vous vous et les
enfants oui et qu'est-ce qu'ils font par
un scandale énorme il dort 6 réveil qui
voit 80 personnes en 2007 eur et baby
sitter qui est chargé de vaquer ce qui
est chargé de fermer la porte
et qu'est ce qui se passe dans le genre
de soirée où
on commence par way
et puis après le dîner en
descend on danse aux mains des scooters
une petite discothèque
on en vient d'être maman passionnée par
anticipation
organisé pour 80 personnes pourraient
vraiment très très fortunés ou pour
s'offrir ce plaisir donc une
participation
donc après le repas en descend on danse
et puis suivant les soirs ça démarre tôt
quitté suivant les soirs c'est un petit
peu plus de temps y en a qui discutent y
en a
qui directement les maquis 2010 l'an
passé une soirée sans pour autant sexy
des méthodes et la fréquence et tous les
combien toutes les semaines tous les
mois un mot no non à l'heure actuelle ce
à peu près une fois par mois
maximum une permanence au score
relativement dur d'organiser je vous dis
tout de suite ce pas facile avant pour
dauphiné puis privé sans rien à voir et
quand on va partir au final à
deauville ouais
pense qu'il ya deux choses par deux
ponts il ya là de l'avenue foch way est
bon la plus proche à beaucoup d'hommes
qui sont sur le trottoir ouais et qui
avant un couple donc faire un trio il ya
des fois y'a tout cas deux hommes
avec marc ria des couples qui sillonnent
la venue qui sillonnent tout autour de
la porte dauphine ouais et qui cherche
un ou plusieurs coups pour se retrouver
donc chez un des couples qui a un local
disponible soit bien aussi quelque chose
de complètement insensé mais derrière
derrière la porte dauphine est tout
petit contrat les way où on est allé
pour voir un peu ce qui se passait ce
qu'on nous avait dit qu'il se passait
des choses un peu bizarre et j'avais
demandé llanelli qui est qui et par une
chrome est presque de de montrer un
petit peu ses charmes et la pala pas
hésité on s'égare et donc dans cette
petite contre allée à commencer un petit
pas se garer c'est entre un peu ses
seins et là on a été cerné par les beats
on s'est retrouvés il y avait 30 mai qui
s'est déclaré vers
cette vérité tu tournes dans ce genre de
sujet et là c'était hallucinant parce
qu'on s'est retrouvés avec des démos
d'arcins pas des routiers antipathique
enfin mort de deux personnes et je dois
dire que j'ai vraiment eu presque peur
ouais et on sait on s'est fait courser
même moment par des parrains un troupeau
de mecs l'habitat la main et j'ai été
obligé de foncer dans le tas parce que
sinon on se faisait j'en sais rien ce
qu'on se faisait mais ça l'est ça veut
dire d'aller mal quoi c'est un petit peu
normal et après on est obligé de mettre
les essuie-glaces
essuie glace était moi j'avais jamais vu
ça je n'osais pas pu toucher la voiture
gm josé enfin sortir de la voiture parce
que bon c'est une voiture de location
est une voiture de location sur le
ramener comme on a arrangé un petit peu
on avait pris du sopalin avant
voilà on a nettoyé un peu puis
vous par exemple si vous êtes mariés
depuis 13 ans oui je sais pas quand tu
vois ta femme dans les bras d'un autre
mec que cette fête ça lui fait plaisir
et vous pareil quand vous le voyez que
votre bébé ça vous fait plaisir et au
mexique est ce que ça a changé vos
relations à la maison je veux dire avant
demain matin vous vous retrouvez vous
êtes exactement après vous prenez votre
petit déjeuner tous les deux les enfants
avec les enfants ça nous est même arrivé
de passer des week-ends avec des couples
ouais partager nos jeux et une fois que
s'est terminée la vie continue tout à
fait normalement c'est quand même un peu
la porte ouverte et l'adultère je n'y
vois pas par contre je n'avais pas eu
envie que tu vas vous rencontrez
quelqu'un dans une soirée comme ça il
vous plaît qui cherchait alors à voir
tout seul maintenant justement pas loin
non les conventions il ya cette
complicité entre
jeu mais ce que tu as des conventions
des pins qui doivent être respectées
sinon il ya danger c'est encore possible
après de faire l'amour tous les deux je
dire pendant la semaine mieux que ça
même avant
on se refuse pas non plus un terrain
inconnu 79 autres non ça je
crois qu'il faut bien qu'il faut bien
mettre les pendules à l'heure et
surgissent mme c'est pas c'est pas la
prostitution ouais c'est pas de la
prostitution c'est à dire que on le fait
avec une partenaire qui échappe aux
partenaires pour une dame on le fait
donc la catho faire s'il vous plaît ou
ça passe avec n'importe qui c'est pas la
bonne ou non des enquêtes âge aux
enfants gym
sept ans l'autre quatre ans je suis un
jour elle s'en aperçoit je veux dire
parce qu'après baby sitter le pape a
relaté enfermé dans la chambre jusqu'à
l'âge de 20 ans non si un jour elle
ouvre la porte et quelle voix 80
personnes comme ça en train de enfin de
carrelage elle aura déjà du mal à le
voir mais quand même suffisamment
discret et
bon plus on est assez franc avec elle
elle sait à peu près ce qui se passe
elles jugent pas parce que chez nous
c'est quelque chose qui naturel avis il
n'y a pas de nature et l'imam a donc la
mise à mort d'un journaliste en
admettant qu'elles sont eux sachant pour
aller au tout les sépare le grand père
et qu'elle voit un couple
attention ne font pas un complément
n'importe quoi dans la wilaya connaît
des emplacements non
en admettant qu'elle sorte qu'à loyen
coupe
en train de faire sa toilette parce que
rien ne vienne ouais
le couple s'est tourné
ici un jour je sais pas par exemple à
l'âge de 18 ans elle a envie de
participer ou serait d'accord ou pas de
toute façon nous on est assez libéré
branchements pour
sa ligne de vie j'envoie l'interdirait
pacha ce qu'elle voudra partir mans où
elle soit
elle est bien dans sa tête ou c'est pas
quelque chose qu'elle va faire pour
faire comme tout le monde avec une idée
derrière la tête vos avis sont courants
tu vois si la plupart des gens qui ne
connaissent même s'ils viennent pas à
quoi je veux dire voilà pourquoi la
famille est au courant la famille est au
courant moi il ya d'ailleurs mon
beau-père
et vous il ya longtemps que fait ça
alors nous embarque à la main pour y
croire la première pause et s'est passé
comment commencer les qui vous en a
parlé oui c'est gentiment la peur et
puis bah notre moi je suis habitué je
vois pas ça ça vous manquerez si vous ne
soyez plus je pense que j'avais tous les
vendredis oui ce qu'on a l'intention oui
c'est pas tous les vendredis et même un
bon moyen d'un week-end atomic anne qu'à
l'habitude
c'est pas trop quoi faire puis bon ça
coûte rien ouais c'est un délit c'est un
des seuls plaisirs qui en général goût
de rien vraiment sublime nous pensons
pas encore passé bon on va faire ou un
petit tour dans une soirée privée bon on
a compris chez nicolas encore ouais ou
alors il faut envoyer au japon deux
raisons ou alors on va c'est un petit
tour francophile quand on a fait il ya
trois jours mais en parlant de taxation
il n'y a pas de problème avec les flics
par exemple quand même c'est pas un
dernier pour nous chez nous dans un
cadre privé haut de gamme à des crises
des fois qu'ils passent avec des
voitures moins dans l'ue ou moins
banalisé et qu'ils disent oui bien
appliqué mais d'aller chez le flécher le
mec qu'on va chercher vos postes non la
somme non ils baladent avec une voiture
qui maintenant de réaliser du tout c'est
un blanc sans gros ait au bureau par
wayne donc on les voit de loin on y voit
loin même si tout est en général et de
monde circuler ah ouais c'est tout ce
qu'est ce que vous attendez là lors dit
rien on est alors circulé mais voilà des
vapeurs en ce moment l'équipe la maladie
queiroz
capuchon comme dirait un touchant ouais
alors le la prochaine soirée s'est pas
passé elle donne à ses deux mains
tendues d'ailleurs
ben ça c'est très dur parce que c'est
très dur il faut quand même assez
méfiants alors voilà président je vais
vous présenter monsieur fatale qui
désormais avant on avait un mage
maintenant on a on a choisi eric
monsieur fatale qui tirent les tarots à
la nos invités principaux chaque semaine
alors la question à laquelle je voudrais
que les cartes répondre mon cher eric
c'est parce que le président
hambourgeois revenir à la télévision
dans les mois qui viennent ah si si si
si nous allons laisser parler les cartes
l'écart clé souverain monégasque
metronomy à je vous demanderai de battre
le cas après que quatre fois il sera
bien les mélanges et donc bien mettre
sur votre énergie j'attends un peu aux
briques et surtout au poker
tu peux faire
à contre coeur
voilà voilà
[Musique]
le fils a sacré
très important de rapporter les coureurs
le drapeau mouche et donc l'autre sur la
marmite
nom se doit pour trois noms en
allant prendre neuf cartes
ici
donc là la réponse à cette question
fondamentale professionnelle la réponse
immédiate est la suivante sa libre et
vous allez progresser il ya un progrès
évident
certaines sphères qui vous retiennent un
petit peu en ce moment alors
heureusement mais le progrès est assurée
c'est une réponse positive agissez avec
prudence
et avec eux
prudence et attention aux détails mais
je pense que le contrat est assuré il ya
un progrès assuré en heures
à quoi vous attendre dans le futur
immédiat la réconciliation des perçu 100
l'éclaircissement la réconciliation qui
découlera de discussion vive et animée
il y aura beaucoup d'opposition mais je
pense que cette opposition va former
fusion est une réponse positive
d'ailleurs que ces pierres progrès il a
éclairci chiker simone cesser dans la
bonne foi toutefois pendant la venue
voir la troisième carte indique les
facteurs caché subconscient c'est à dire
ce qui se passe au fin fond des choses
encore des cas le progrès vous allez
gagner une victoire assurée qui viendra
de beaucoup de conflits certainement
mais la victoire est la
victoire
je passais en de 10,2 passé c'était
l'idéal pourquoi est ce que cette idée à
ne semblerait pas le poste idéal était
donc passé le dénouement possible
prudent soyez prudent pas de nomi pas de
budget énorme pour commencer je lumière
une certaine cependant
quand on était à tf1 je dis on n'est pas
beaucoup de pognon c'est la carte de la
gestion c'est à dire la carte de la
gestion intelligente et sage vingt
quatre progrès dans le futur carrément
même le besoin d'une certaine avarice
voir au niveau de l'avarice plutôt que
di gennaro sera plutôt une chaîne tarifs
pour commencer c'est seulement au départ
en progressant un peu plus loin à il y
aura de colère beaucoup de caractère un
temps précieux
essayé de tempérer votre
koné
sérieusement c'est pas d'être trop
colérique la diplomatie l'équilibré est
à protéger en progressant dans le futur
la chance est avec vous ma changera avec
vous profiter de cette chance finalement
beaucoup de chance tout va bien se
passer chez dire c'est tout à fait
possible
c'est la roue de la fortune la roue
tourne et donc de donner naissance de
nouveaux projets tout à fait valable est
tout à fait positif les cartes sont
extrêmement favorables à la situation
mais de toute manière là où la fortune
et en votre faveur de les naissances à
langres forage sur votre chaîne
[Rires]
princess erika trop de blabla c'est dans
toutes les radios l'année dont
[Musique]
la
tragédie mais déjà
trop c'est trop
me grey cette année trop de blabla j'ai
donné des
oui je
la fais propos d'un sujet
[Musique]
sur le toit
ça m'a plu
[Musique]
s'ouvrir
et cookies des médias
ja
c
d et quand je le découvre il sombre dans
la guerre
[Musique]
ce blabla mais 17 ans la traque des
données déjà
traqueur beaucoup
[Musique]
des jeunes
a big two les verts
trop de temps
ouah
[Musique]
je n'ai pas d'intelligence mais pourtant
mis à jour
[Musique]
je lis loiret
mais pour moi ça combiné qu'une montrait
l'incohérence
profitez-en
et nos bagages
[Musique]
quand j'ai été défaillant et non pas des
critiques ni notre agent
[Musique]
mais dit s'attendre à d'autres attaques
des dons
[Musique]
alors président bush je peux vous êtes
des présidents camp surtout que c'est
grâce à douchez la télé j'ai encore
président mais le décrochage c'était les
sociétés
oui alors il met à ça fait un an oui je
m'en suis aperçu tout à fait par hasard
parce qu'un journaliste m'a téléphoné en
me disant quitte donc qu'est ce qu'on
pensait d'un an privatisations très
fragile et pourquoi ça fait un art déjà
je crois et prières le jour de passage
de tf1 chaîne publique a ajouté la
chaîne privée je serai content
on dépasse un peu l'audiovisuel rit on
parle un peu d'eau mais n'entend pas de
grandes idées tiers monde ça veut dire
quoi est rien on passait bien
maintenant on sait pas ce que ça veut
dire pour les uns ce avait une
connotation péjorative
voulu dire sur lui
sacré c'est plutôt problèmes extérieurs
qu'intérieurs et puis en plus
avaient une vision un petit peu
doctrinaire
du tiers-monde fin du tour en matière
monde il c'est quelqu'un qui s'intéresse
effectivement au pays avec lequel nous
avons eu l'histoire je pense qu'il ya
des cas bien sûr et sans lesquelles la
politique extérieure française serait
réduite à celle de la belgique ou les
pays bas et je pense qu'en ce sens
s'intéresser à ce qui se passe en
afrique c'est s'intéresser à l'évolution
du monde j'ai aidé la franche foire
alors on dit aussi que vous êtes un
chrétien bochum 16e à sion sais rien
je prenais tout ce que ça veut dire je
trouve que j'ai été aussi dans ma vie
tiens bah oui je suis baptisée peut-être
l'employeur d'être comme vous
les citoyen croyant et pratiquant ces
vos idées sont plus très croyant oui
plutôt où j'ai pas porté sa chaîne
appartient à aucun parti aucun je n'ai
jamais appartenu à aucun parti je sais
et un certain nombre de convictions de
fidélité d'amitié je crois que c'est
important dans la vie d'avoir des
convictions j'ai horreur du sectarisme
j'ai horreur par exemple dans une france
coupée en deux j'ai horreur de
considérer comme adversaire quelqu'un
qui ne pense pas comme moi j'ai horreur
en gros tout ce qui n'est pas la liberté
j'ai toujours défendu ses idées là alors
que tiago je veux bien parce que j'ai
été pendant étant rédacteur en chef d'un
journal chrétien le témoignage chrétien
mais ça remonte à très longtemps alors
vous avez un subside plusieurs
surnombres les deux et là c'est le roi
bourse et les pas vous étiez président
de tf1 et cela été données elle veut
s'ouvrir à l'époque par l'express oui
vous l'avez donné aussi arthur qu'on
intègre roi arthur
il est trop vous appelez moi mais parce
que vous êtes parti en 62 chez ben bella
oui alors appelez moi m c et puis même
chose sur le méchant c'est minutes ccc
d'extrême droite moi ça me ça me gêne
pas du tout jaloux rien ou du maroc et
sa fille oui oui et puis moi mettre ses
prophètes si oui alors c'est papa ça me
gêne pas du tout au contraire je dirais
que ça fait plaisir à des tas d'amis de
l'autre côté de la méditerranée moi ça
ne me gêne pas sa main ça me fait plutôt
rire mais vous avez dit un jour
président et finalement la france serait
plus en plus métissée je crois qu'en
d'avoir dit je crois au jo du juge et du
site et léopold sédar senghor le petit
hic l'avenir de l'humanité c'est le
métissage culturel il avait raison
justement vous vous pensez pas qu'en
algérie on aurait pu arriver à une
algérie métissé est ce que les pieds
noirs auraient pu rester et est-ce que
vous éprouviez réellement la la
la situation telle qu'elle est en soit
une chose je crois que l'indépendance de
l'algérie était inéluctable n'est pas le
seul à le penser puisque général de
gaulle l'a réalisé
je pense que si cette guerre n'avait pas
duré si longtemps
tes pieds noirs auraient pu rester car
c'étaient des enfants du pays
au même titre que les algériens de
souche et je pense qu'on aurait réussi
de belles choses
blanc historique malheureusement on ne
fait pas toujours ce qu'on veut vous le
voyez benbella des fois non jamais non
plus du tout depuis très longtemps
d'abord parce que je ne sais pas où il
est
ensuite parce que
pas d'accord avec les orientations qu'il
a pu prendre et ça va je les iraniens
aujourd'hui non c'est ce que l'on vient
vous l'avez vous n'avez plus jamais eu
de non j'ai pas de taxer les banques
c'est bien connu quand il était en
prison en france je les ai revus ensuite
jusqu'à sa chute entre 62 et le 19 juin
1965 gelé ensuite accueilli à paris
lorsque il a été libéré
venue quelques temps une 6 et normal
j'avais été son collaborateur
depuis je n'ai plus compacte est partie
on disait à l'époque dans certains
journaux plutôt de droite effectivement
au d'extrême droite que vous étiez un
porteur de valises du réseau jeanson ça
veut dire quoi les porteurs de valises
du réseau jeanson est aidée pour cissé
est décédé des français qui était calé
le fln et il y avait effectivement le
réseau jeanson du nom francis jeanson le
philosophe et des ses réseaux alors je
n'ai jamais connu francis jeanson j'ai
fait sa connaissance il ya quelques
temps des années après les événements
d'algérie et ensuite
mon éthique
m'aurait pas permis
de réaliser cela je vous le rappeler
j'ai fait mon service militaire pendant
27 mois en algérie j'ai même lu ce que
ça peut être sympa la valeur militaire
j'ai fait
mon métier de soldat même si j'étais
opposé à la guerre d'algérie mais il ne
me serait jamais venu à l'idée de
partager de la musique à fond ses
compétences c'est fou quand même c'est
complètement faux et en plus je ne
connaissais pas conscience mais ça ne
fait rien ça fait partie disons des
légendes et des casseroles qu'il traîne
derrière vous parce que certains l'ont
écrit ça a été reprise je suis pas
permis d'ailleurs même de de démentir
cela parce que j'estimais que de telles
bassesses maintenant c'était oui c'est
fait et si on vous propose une chaîne
après le 9 mai alors je vois pas
pourquoi on proposerait une chaîne après
le 9 mai
d'une part d'autre part celle du coup si
j'accepterais et enfin j'attends pas ça
tu voulais j'ai voulu me prouver à moi
même que je n'avais pas besoin
d'attendre des autres quoi que ce soit
j'ai monté mon affaire et que je voulais
moi même prouvé que si j'avais été
président terrain convenable se pouvait
dans le domaine de la communication
continuer de travailler en utilisant mes
propres forces a souvent vous la propose
ou la prendre les consommateurs pour ces
raisons pas pourquoi on leur proposerait
en tout cas
shakur pas dans ma tête
à brigitte lahaie une cassette qui sort
de goût qui s'appelle l'anthologie du
plaisir j'ai pas mal mais c'est une
caissette qui retrace les miens ça sera
des films x que j'ai tourné entre 65 et
80 ouais et c'est vrai que j'aime bien
cette cassette c'est bien la dernière
fois qu'on vous avez à la télé c'était
chez pivot
oui enfin lundi dernier un portant oui
très important le bouquin s'est bien
rendu très bien dans ce genre en livre
de poche mais faut les armer
on apprenait dans ce bouquin vous avez
connu votre première jouissance en
faisant du vélo sur une scène de vélo
c'est c'est vrai ça c'est une invention
tout ce qui est dans le vrai j'ai fait
des mensonges par omission mais j'ai
fait j'étais aucun mensonge il n'y a pas
de mensonge y a un truc est très honnête
aussi dans le livre c'est à dire que
finalement vous de faire l'amour devant
une caméra ça vous excite plus tôt quand
vous faites pas comme certaines qui
disent moi je suis comédienne tout ça je
fais ça pour gagner ma vie mais
bon c'est vrai j'ai pris j'ai pris
beaucoup de plaisir à faire ces films et
je renie rien
vous reconnaissez dans le bouquin que
vous êtes un peu avec ses fils younes
est un peu voyages allemandes conseillé
pas de jouer un alibi culturel ou alibi
comédienne quoi je crois que la libye
culturel en ayant plus des films x
aurait été très difficile à jouer de
toute façon mais non c'est s étaient
incités par plaisir que je joue j'ai
j'en ai marre j'ai arrêté et j'ai fait
autre chose quand vous cachez pas dès
mai 2006 délai sa commande et j'aime
beaucoup d'érotisme ouais vous dites
vous dit dans le cas où vous dites que
vous avez participé d'ailleurs à des
partouzes au roi rené ad oui à la bonne
époque comme on dit ouais c'est vrai
entre jusqu'en jusqu'à 80 c'est vrai
qu'un jour il ya une star de la chanson
et du cinéma qui est venu et qui s'est
fait sans mec comme ça c'est tout à fait
vrai mais il ya pas mal de gens comme
nous qui vivons mais en fait si leur vie
privée donc on restait très loin vous
pouvez passer des ventes la nonchalance
travaux publics on dit un truc dans le
vif qui a ses fans que je savais pas
c'est que le sperme des cas pas tout le
temps le même moule c'est vrai il n'a du
sucré du salé
ouais donc c'est bien quoi je veux dire
la transpiration n'a pas le même
ça va du sucre et au plus salée si je
peux dire ouais passant par les pisse et
enfin ouais ça vous dit que c'est une
chose a expliqué aux femmes parce que si
des fois un jour elles en ont goûté
inquiétez pas ils étaient 10 rebonds
voilà elle vaudra plus jamais en goûter
alors c'est sûr leur explique que ça
peut avoir un goût différent finalement
c'est vrai ça peut être très bon c'est
une question de mois j'ai un palais
plutôt sucré si vous avez un palais
plutôt salée cette question ne vous dit
que vous êtes clitoridienne vous n'êtes
pas lesbienne vous n'aimez pas ça non
c'est pas incompatibles mais dans les
films par contre c'est quand même bien
fait d scène de lesbianisme oui c'est
donc pour ça que je peux dire je n'aime
pas ça ça me plaisait pas c'est un
ventre comme si c'était moi j'aime bien
les orgues ouais quand j'aime bien les
hommes qui pour front des choses les
flammes sous contrat de l'enfer les
hommes à gré à faire ça aussi quand même
mais quand vous et c'est avec une fille
dans un filtre
ça me gêne pas gêné je vous dégoûtez pas
je veux faire du tout je n'ai jamais
fait de choses qui me d'éviter
alors vous dites aussi un truc que je
savais pas du tout c'est que les filles
qui font de la sodomie dans les films
pornos on les met un petit peu à part
commence à se poser est pourquoi cet
ostracisme et passe beaucoup de choses
et gérons bien non je crois que c'est
non ce que ce que j'ai dit dieu du
vouloir dire c'est que les filles qui
font uniquement ce ça se gâte est le
double des comédiens qui refusent de le
faire bon elles ont un côté comme ça je
suis presque comme les cascadeurs donc
c'est pas tout à fait la même chose je
vais cascadeuse du film porno c'est ça
vite que c'est souvent des filles qui se
défoncent
qui sera concélébrée ouais c'est vrai ça
va peut-être qu'il abhorre jeudi soir
mais vous vous les mettez un peu dans la
même
même catégorie mais je crois je crois
que de toute façon il ya beaucoup de
gens qui se droguent ses tournages là
vous n'avez jamais été en contact avec
ça moi c'est pas mon truc d'un problème
même pas fume un joint je suis même pas
de
champagne
lanson
le dernier pornographie 180 en 81 81
c'étaient les petites écolières de
frédéric en cela très bien alors depuis
grâce à canal qu il est devenu beaucoup
plus rares qu'à l'époque finalement bien
passé dans 12 salles classées x non
c'est surtout grâce à la vidéo puisque
depuis 80 les vidéos des films se
vendent surtout en vidéo le spectateur
n'a pratiquement plus en salle et par
contre les vidéos se vend très bien que
vous faites alors maintenant bah écoutez
j'ai tourné un film
policiers avec des scènes très fort qui
sort le 15 juin avec le boël umberger
son partenaire comment il est maintenant
à écouter il est bien conservé ah oui
tout à fait ça donne de 40 ans voilà way
est toujours son regard inquiétant
et puis les très agréable c'est vrai tu
commences tu sais c'est pas les
prédateurs de la nuit et ce sont les
tiens je suis réalisé par qui jusqu'en
côte jess franco produit par rené
château est alors maintenant est ce que
vous allez faire comme les sportifs
une fois qu'ils ont quitté le sport
lance des lignes de vêtements ou est-ce
que vous allez pas réagi
dans le set projets dans ce style là
c'est de partir de septembre je dirige
une collection de n'ouvrir aux tic chez
hachette voilà et donc je suis en train
en ce moment dans l'urne énormément bon
donc je n'ai jamais bien de choses vous
les envoyer voilà les envoyer je vais te
le dire les meilleurs ça fait comment
cette production logica et présente
carrément comme gérant des libyens c'est
vrai vous en sortez bien alors c'est
vague ils ont copine en face à vos
copines derrière mais aux
celtics et de même beaucoup à l'époque
l'idée car il est devenu voit par
exemple que tim beccari elle travaille
travaille plus du dessous je crois que
dans une ferme avec des animaux elle
avait complètement bouclé passer vos
fils
je crois pas non non moi je suis via
bordeaux qu'est ce que je sais pas
dernièrement je crois qu'elle est et
qu'elle était elle travaille dans une
galerie d'art
rassurant dans domaine artistique si je
puis dire mais je sais pas exactement
j'avoue que je nie tout contact vu
jamais de regrets d'avoir fait ça non je
n'ai jamais jamais cru parce que rien de
manier civile et à devenir comédienne et
c'est grâce à ça que j'ai découvert mon
amant du cinéma
le plaisir d'être devant une caméra ou y
est celle actuellement pour les
émissions de télé
lui et c'est là vous avez choisi la voie
la plus faste je voulais non je voulais
je voulais devenir quelqu'un ouais je
veux pas être la femme de quelqu'un je
voulais devenir quelqu'un je voulais
être un individu bon peut-être que je
crois que j'ai choisi la voie la plus
difficile la voile a pu noter chaque
fois c'est pas la voie la plus facile
vous êtes mariés non non vous êtes avec
quelqu'un je j'ai lui
mais qu'est ce que justement les visages
arrivés que c'est bien pour un dîner
chez des gens pareils
et brigitte balleys comment savez c'est
toujours quand de mode pour un homme
d'avoir une femme qui fait beaucoup de
choses et lincou l'a choisi lui devient
trop sagement c'est certainement très
rebelle horizons pour lui je serai là je
pense qu'il est ravi et très fâcheux
joueurs en tout cas je pense qu'il
fallait et ça ne gêne pas de le voir des
enfants c'est pas c'est pas prévu dans
les
prochains stages docteur non j'ai pas
j'ai mis un an pour l'instant j'ai pas
envie d'en avoir d'autres parce que je
ne m'appuie de mettre pas encore
totalement réalisée
réalisez-vous à monter
album sylvain bergère 30 2 avec andrée
putman
people are said
fred versailles le pote de khrouchtchev
liane foly ça va ça vient
django et loire
est ce que tu me dis
groseille aubin
michel déon salut
christian pées s'il
la nouvelle eve fait de l' agence bddp
le psychédélique revient en force
[Musique]
cabanes arisem 42 rue fontaine dans le
neuvième tous les samedis yannick
organise une soirée consacrée au jazz 40
c'est magnifique
[Musique]
you can't see is my reality
la locomotive boulevard rochechouart
dans le 9e
oui mais le décor est mieux plaqueur
[Musique]
oulala
suite des aventures de sylvain chapitre
30/2 silva à montmartre
[Musique]
c'est très très bon des leggings
ou là
philippe à quelques heures des élections
et avant de parler avec bernard le
grelle de la profession l'aube liman qui
suit est intéressant un lobby qui est le
lobby des les automobilistes oui j'ai
voulu clore la campagne électorale
dignement pour bonne nuit et alors le
gros problème aujourd'hui la seule
question parce que je veux dire que
mitterrand soit élu ou pas personne on a
rien à ce qui intéresse les gens c'est
d'aileurs sauver leur pays c'est de
faire sauter leur pv il ya plus ya eu
plus de 30 % de morts sur les routes
depuis le début de l'année à cause de ça
c'est l'hécatombe total est le principal
lobby en france aujourd'hui c'est celui
des pv les parcmètres l'epg les
papillons des aubergines et ses terres
externe quand je me suis dit que le
meilleur moyen de savoir si vraiment ces
partis politiques étaient up to day tout
ça qu'on dit c'est d'aller les voir au
dans leurs singes comme sa tournée par
le climat oui voilà et alors c'est
d'aller les voir dans leur sein et je
suis allé dans les permanences j'ai fait
la tournée des cinq permanences des cinq
partis politiques groupes parlementaires
de l'assemblée nationale puisque comme
on est contrôlé il faut faire attention
de rêve de bien répartir les temps de
parole et donc j'ai été dans les cinq
permanences avec un micro hf une caméras
planquées malheureusement n'a pas pu
faire rentrer la camry dehors parce que
t'as pas pu rentrer à gilbert lamerat
est dehors donc j'ai vu les cinq partis
et on a été voir un petit peu qu'est ce
qu'il était capable de faire contre ma
voix est là d'un spot pour vous à
combustion nouvelle passe sautée mais
bébé voilà parce qu'on n'est sûr de rien
avec les et les amnisties tu vois on
peut se faire avoir donc je préfère
anticiper donc si sylvie un parti
politique et même encore là il leur
reste encore 24 heures moi aussi
d'ailleurs fera non j'avais perdu ma
xiaowei à peine osé des impôts des trucs
un sanctuaire réglé donc je savais c'est
au père m'a dit reste 24 heures donc
cours et avocats manens politique étant
dans 24 heures tout sera fini
mais bon
et pas vous passer un pv et vous lui
filer un député ou un autre comme ça
parce que comme moi je fais de l'arabe
en plus dans mon entreprise pour bar we
do ré j'en ai journée au moins j'en ai
une dizaine quoi éclairer comme ça donc
moi si je collais place et si je peux en
faire sauter quelques uns aussi bien oui
non faucher pas c'est pas moi c'est pour
moi le reste on comment je fais alors je
vais à la permanence de qui non mais
faisons bien monsieur qui est la 2e
mais c'est possible tu vaux débat non
mais moi je suis prêt à voter pour bar
mais simplement comme ya eu plein de
bruit comme quoi les pv étaient allés
pas y aller pas y avoir des mines ici
avec bar ce que je veux c'est que vous
vous arrangez pour mes tv voyez puis
après tout pourquoi pas marchandé sa
voix pour cela meilleurs moyens de
fonctionner 12 bah oui souffrir du
marchand bon bah on voir un psy merci
[Musique]
la par un député qui puisse où une
permanence de député je puisse aller où
il demandé d'en faire sauter un je vous
jure que moi je reviens à mon bureau
après je leur dis regardez un élu udc
dans l'ancienne sernam non mais j'ai pas
la race to c
il est cool là dessus je sais pas
je peux pas te dire qu'ils le feront
mais c'est pas un magouilleur je vais
juste en faire sauter un comme ça après
je vais au bureau et se dit regardez
vous baratine et n'empêche que si vous
votez à gauche s'ils ont une facilité le
voir par un élu parce que il faut voir
je peux presque moi je dire ça va pas
vous coûter grand chose d un bébé ça me
fait ça me fait au moins 83 voix j'ai
bien que les deux secrétaires et je
gagnais un des représentants il est prêt
à voter pour un terrain alors là moi je
crois de gaza mais aussi les
minoritaires merci au revoir un bon
courage pour eux peuvent échanger son
vol mais qu'y faire quand même voyez pas
pour vraiment être un électeur un petit
peu je dirais non mais au ras des
pâquerettes parce que moi ils ne
feraient pas changé il ne ferait pas
changer mon vote pour mtv mais en fait
tu es sérieux quid des autres problèmes
que nous avons et l'immigration et
l'émigration la hongrie de l'islam en
france et vous n'avez pas un pv mais le
programme se fera baiser par un gamin
des arabes parce que c'est ça devrait
arriver à lure quelques des enfants sont
violés tout ça est que les gens n'auront
plus rien à dire en france parce que ce
sera 10 lames pour faire jeter les
périphs autres copains car un gardien de
la paix c'est avec un petit fait les
choeurs un petit flic amis à vous et
vous le fait sauter
arrête là pour l'oeuvre au revoir
au revoir madame mon corps à sion
c'est pas des grosses sommes donc un
plus plus récents vous allez tout de
suite de façon à ce que les gars aient
commencé à porter à profession d'accord
ou d'accord et là je vais aussi hc saint
germain c'est ça c'est will we hill ou
benoît saint germain il y avait 2 et là
qu'est ce que je fais je demande qui je
présente au planton à l'entrée je dis
voilà que vous demandez à monter hors
pair vous monte facilement
au revoir
autre mystère bah moi je suis proche non
c'est pas maintenant toujours devant le
but et mais vous pouviez vous faire à
moi ou avec ses députés du pc vous
pouvez pas faire sauter les grêlons à
deux députés eux-mêmes - si je passerai
que si je passe mes pv ce que les
députés par et qui peuvent les faire
sauter les pv
je m'en remettre
ce que moi si je m'inscris au parti moi
je veux bien qu'on me fasse sauter les
pv près tous les élections c'est aussi
pour nous rendre service à nos au muy a
pas de raison de s'en priver tout à
dieu tu m'en rappeler sa mise en jeu
réfléchir parce qu'il faut qu'on joue
avec ma forme est toujours d'accord non
pas maintenant tout me remplit ça on se
voit a déjà voix du genre humain tel on
signale si vous regardez vous donc moi
ce qui m'a épaté sexuelle il y en a un
seul on va pas leur faire de plus on va
pas répéter le nom il n'y a qu'un seul
parti en plus pas le plus pâti
finalement marché dans la courbe et 90
où les eaux traitées mais aucun problème
ça ça n'a posé aucun problème d'arrivée
finalement je vote pour vous si vous
faites sauter mais pvd max en vacances
je crois que finalement c'est la plus
grande preuve qu'une fois encore on a là
un lobby fantastique et ce qui m'étonne
c'est que bernard le grelle pour le
lobby manon qui est l'auteur de
profession le big man ne s'en serait
jamais occupé il est étonnante avec tes
jamais trop tard pour bien faire leur
profession lobby malbon pas de
traduction en français parce qu'en
français lobby valse se traduit par marc
poulin magouilleurs
manipulateur combinat marchand d'accès
corrupteurs donc est-ce que la première
chose ce serait pas déjà trouvé un nom
pour expliquer aux gens ce qu'est un
volume allant de bannir fait le big man
et très bonne presse en france quand
même oui puis tournerait pas un lobby a
créé pour défendre c'est le début est
qu'à ses débuts du lobby ouais mais
gérer que aux etats-unis aussi a
mauvaise presse parce que ça bon endroit
pour en parler le vix est très écrit aux
états unis où était décrit par les 3b
oui vous l'avez l'alcool un blog chez
les femmes c'est priceless alors c'est
vrai que le média très mauvaise c'est un
peu le meeting urbaine notamment c'est
un peu le métier
on y viendra alors devenir pourquoi ce
bouquin hachette qui est quand même
passé pas des mécènes pour cause on a
envoyé dix mille exemplaires au pilon
enfin parce que c'était sortir à la fin
de l'année va sans dire
et
un de vos confrères l'express devait
sortir les bonnes feuilles on à bord est
pris comme exemple le bi côté tunnel
sous la manche et ça n'a pas plu à tout
le monde alors voilà il ya eu des
presses des amicales pressions et puis
les avocats les avocats doit nous
séparer survenant aussi des noms des
noms moi j'en sais rien mais je crois
qu'il ya les gens du tunnel n'ont pas
beaucoup apprécié et bouygues peut-être
par bernard sik la tct plus gros coup
comme comme lobby man alors cela monte
mon plus gros ou kiki marc attentes
ayant pas mal d'argent et qui a rapporté
encore beaucoup plus d'argent mes
clients c'est le monopole postal ah ça
c'est un coup c'est qu'avant en france
était la poste et transporteurs
étrangers plis tout ouais on est des
trucs amassé pays qu'on a eu le fameux
mardi noir est large et en suisse on
m'appelait d'urgence parce que à 6
heures du matin les douaniers et les crs
ont attaqué les plates formes
aéroportuaires de à orly et de roissy
tout saisi ouais et alors c'était très
drôle parce qu'avais l'avion du
président bongo qui est en réparation
les connaissement étaient bloquées et le
bateau que pas déchargés à marseille si
la queue dans les dents les décida d'y
arriver des états unis par courrier
privé on a trouvé une latte de
mitterrand aux abords d'un système où le
discours de mitterrand les projets pour
le discours de mitterrand qui est parti
en voyage officiel aux états unis ce qui
va secte qui couvait que mitterrand
utiliser le musée l'elysée y compris les
ptt qui avaient souscrit un abonnement
de l'argent quand même génial d'un
député en france combien ça coûte alors
non la sacha pas non non transformé en
vient jeudi
ou bien combien ça coûte un décolleté en
france le problème c'est que les députés
ils veulent tous pareils j'imagine aux
états unis vote obligatoire comme la
roma montre pas mais aussi très souvent
les brumes est apte et après je les
trois le ps même le fait saillant
copeaux pour certains dossiers de désir
d envoyer de positif et moi j'ai écouté
d'abord ce ballon d'argent un vrai
client et on va voir mais j'aime bien
mes clients de l'eepad si jolie alain
une fourchette combien sa note a débuté
parce que si on enregistre alors combien
ça claque administrée
c'est très cher ça va chercher dans les
milieux dans la vidéo de francs français
et un journaliste a trouvé ce
journalisme a demandé avec ironie alors
ça me ferait chier pâtes et riz
couvertures gros là bas moi je gagne
bien ma vie par ailleurs je suis pas
achetable voilà mes belles le lobbing ça
peut aller très loin ça peut aller
jusqu'à faire flinguer les gens
c'est plutôt comment nous c'est de
savoir parce que ça mais jenner
oui mais ces confessions âge si les
niçois très repas par an passé
grave oui la frontière c'est qu'un jour
je reçois un coup de téléphone du quai
d'orsay messieurs qui se présente je
connaissais que j'ai rencontré plusieurs
fois et m'a dit voilà nous un problème
on a reçu des cassettes vidéo de sabra
et chatila est absolument horrible ce
qui s'est passé là et le gouvernement
français veut faire un lobby enfin nous
on est pro bowl ip modéré et ce moment
le roi hussein de jordanie avait feint
un mouvement il fallait d hussein et la
france l'a fait hier ils ont dit les
américains bloc oui et il faut
convaincre les américains est ce que
parce que j'ai un partenaire américain
que bobby grecque et alors est ce qu il
répété en gros j'ai repris gré à gré oui
je vois ou tchèques rugby
et alors on y est
plombât d'amore ya pas de remords
flashback seul ian churchill cup you
babe
à
hu alors
il
gilani
[Musique]
plus cher 24 ans plus tard plus cher de
24 bâton de chirurgie esthétique
[Musique]
voilà les
à gaspé
allo
[Musique]
j'ai ouvert ma
ça
[Musique]
m
ayant
[Musique]
aïe aïe
il
ah ah
à ado
[Musique]
m
et
il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jean loup dabadie en sait beaucoup de
choses de mouscron c'est moi si vous
avez commencé en écrivant des romans et
les dieux du foyer le premier c'était
les yeux sykes alors comment ça se fait
que ces romans dont le premier était
saluée d'ailleurs comme on parlait de
morand comment se fait-il que vous ayez
pas continuer maintenant et bien parce
que
c'est vrai que l'on m'ait fait ce petit
honneur d'en parler j'étais encore
facilement en classe du mois
l'université
j'avais 18 ans pour le premier 19 ans
pour le second et
ça n'a pas bien marché alors ça méritait
pas des doucets marche jamais bien
pourquoi vous pensez vous les aviez
faire comme françoise sagan et comme
philippe sonnet reçoit peu de temps
avant moi et peu de temps admet way qui
avait eu beaucoup de succès que c'est
dans les lycées est moralement par
l'église de 50 on était fous littérature
fou de philo d'herbe rien on parlait
plus de leur livre quand on était en
finale
plus que temps de lire à ce moment là et
ceux d'entre nous qui rêvions décrit
rêvions de leur carrière donc cinq ans
le succès immédiat de sagan a peut-être
ruiner votre votre carrière de romancier
françois ce que tu me quelqu'un auquel
elle est divine elle est divine là elle
a beaucoup de talent la courage fou
notamment le courage de publier depuis
cette époque où je t'aime jeune homme en
première et en philo et où on lisait
bonjour tristesse un certain sourire et
les livres qui s'en est ensuivie
on rêvait non seulement son destin mais
déjà des cuivres aussi librement et
aussi comme connaître romy schneider
plus tard qu si bellement qu'elle est
évidemment
les uns et les autres les unes et les
autres nous n'avions pas tous la chance
d'être publié moi j'ai eu la chance
d'être publié nous n'avions pas tous la
chance d'avoir du succès je n'ai pas eu
le succès avoir de la chance et quand
j'avais pas de sou il a fallu que
j'apprenne à métier et j'ai été engagé
par paul guimard passer ça mais
lorsqu'on journal français pas non plus
et vous avez bossé avec averti sur les
raisins verts qui était une émission qui
voit me fascine et quand j'étais vous je
crois que cessent les émissions qu'à
former mon goût et maxime soulet parce
que j'étais plus en avance que moi moi
je la faisais j'écrivais des textes
ouais un temps j'en avais peur parce que
à part ma mère qui était qui a toujours
quelqu'un d'une femme moderne le monde
me disait ça c'est la damnation c'était
les enfants la police oui puis c'est
surtout ce qu'on appelait à l'époque
le mauvais goût ouais alors que
jean-christophe est une des premières
personnes à dina mahoungou non
ce qu'ils auraient trouvé lui de mauvais
goût j'ai passé pour que cela ne s'est
pas le bruit sur un bateau si ça c'est
pas supporté mais qu'est-ce que je suis
moi un chien ainsi à qu'est ce que tu
dis un chien est ce qu on l a dit viser
10 heures ce matin avec vous c'est pas
nous écouterons courriel vous tous
cameron voilà c'était le sien et g
quelques années après dans mes lectures
j'ai vu qu'il avait un peu pompé
peut-être sans savoir mais on la vit
parce que c'est quelqu'un de très
cultivé en le sachant sur sur dans jules
renard qui dit quelque part dans son
dans son journal voyons du clan journal
de juin qui ont dit je suis pas sûr
d'avoir bon goût mais je ne débuterai
sur wii
cette phase est patente lui céder sa
alors il nous apprenait sa aux uns aux
autres et parmi les débutants il y avait
huit bouts d'os cela vous êtes plus
c'est là que sam greene ça me gêne quand
vous voyez un film vous avez écrit à la
télé est coupée par des par les foules
tout fait de la peine voilà j'aime bien
ce mot là ça ça me fait de la peine ce
n'est pas systématique si c'est fait pas
sa part
entre pense qu'est ce que j'ai fait mais
pas référence de travail ça me ferait
probablement je n'en sais rien mais
probablement plus de peine
si on coupe
les choses de la vie où vincent françois
paul et les autres que
que le sauvage ou un éléphant ça trompe
énormément parce que ce sont des
comédies mais encore que je pense
beaucoup de lins matin j'aurais cru que
les fans de de jean paul rappeneau
d'yves robert les metteurs en scène de
ses filles mais mes amis mais comment tu
peux dire ça à l'émotion est là même dès
lors qu'on fait rire williams est parti
vous imitez que l'autre sauter se dire
quand vous dos et vous travaillez comme
ça aussi tout le temps sa voix haute les
musiciens disent comment alors à la
seule et peut être parce qu'ils disent
l'oeil comme ça attendez oui c'est pour
ça que c'est ça que ce qui
ce qui me donne le plus de deux tracks
travail ou toujours avec la veille une
peur d'acteur
j'ai toujours peur de commencer une
scène
cet après midi
de vendredi deux fois voire que je vous
ai téléphoné stefan hackh atteint les
gens là est ce que je vois pas venir une
autre fois parce que j'arrivais pas à
entrer dans une scène qui j'avais
électrique et pas une de plus difficile
que j'ai à faire mais c'est le même
combat que pour les acteurs c'est-à-dire
une espèce d'angoissé que en plus de sa
mort mais ça ne l'est pas écrit en
france elle n'est pas prête elle pas qu
est ce qui me rassure c'est d'avoir une
c'est d'avoir une idée des comédiennes
et des comédiens qui vont justement vous
fera gagner parce que
on a eu dans l'émission au jean claude
carrière ou jean bracq kiki quand brad
wright polanski ils sont ensemble quand
carrière travail avec qu'au final ils
sont sans doute travailler tout seul ou
avec le réalisateur son mari yves quand
les réalisateurs sont deux réalisateurs
auteurs quand je ne mange pas les
drapeaux sopave robert copilote au plus
faut quand j'ai eu l'honneur d'écrire un
seul hélas pour moi film pour lui on
travaille ensemble mais une sortie il
arrive aussi quelquefois ce qui est le
cas actuellement que vous ayez une idée
est que comme pour un roman vous savez
c'est la même chose je sais pas ce que
gérard ou ce que jean-claude de carrière
vous ont dit qu'en tant que j'ai vu
l'interview de jean-claude je me
rappelle pas que vous ayez parler de ça
c'est la même chose c'est le bouquin du
film comme me rappeler aux coques qu'on
écrit bon alors évidemment si on est
ensemble si vous êtes le réalisateur ou
si c'est vous l'auteur ch du réalisateur
se fait plaisir de me parler et voir ma
tête
les bons réalisateurs sont d'avant des
bons directeurs d'auteur avant d'être
des bons directeurs d'acteurs de leurs
regards vous tirez votre drôlerie votre
émotion
vos silences votre angoisse votre envie
d'adoucir ce regard vous l'allumez
sentir sa marque dans le gard de l'aude
tout de suite où que ce soit le
lendemain il arrive quelquefois que pour
aller comme pour un livre comme pour une
pièce vous ayez besoin d'être tout seul
pour trouver les besoins ou parce que
vous êtes tout seul des méchantes un
déclin actuel s'appelle forcing nathalie
baye mais il sait pas quel sera le
réalisateur encore avant je préparais de
la finance qui va leur demander au nom
de mon écriture parce que j'ai commencé
à inventer mon histoire à la raconter
aux producteurs aux comédiens
c'est rageant scénariste qui est non non
pas tellement parce que quand vous aurez
fait plein de films plein de chansons
plein disque est celle que vous n'êtes
pas envie de revenir la littérature nous
faire un roman désespéré de 500 pages
d'abord le fou de théâtre à cause des
répétitions à cause du travail physique
avec les acteurs nationaux empêche pas
qu évidemment je rêverais de vrais
d'écrire des livres mais
juste pas sûr d'être actuellement doué
pour pour écrire des livres je suis pas
que le jeu le soap au cinéma pour le
théâtre comme ça le au moins on peut se
parler on on se touche en sport on se
rappelle au téléphone si
écrire un livre c'est mon rêve puisque
si tellement lecteurs de livres je me
fais ce que vous écrivez j'en rêve mais
si je suis ici à propos de règles si je
pouvais la nuit me rappeler au téléphone
pour corriger
[Musique]
à
mua
quant au livre mais chiche en
notre nom mais généralement se voit la
super métro ou encore
robert sofa les taxis vont stagner faire
à votre manque lance non à dornach et de
maintenance non non non non non est un
mec naucelle
marianne rigoberte vous avez le premier
rôle de bagdad café que j'ai vu et je
trouve que c'est un film formidable et
je tiens à vous dire que je suis sûr que
ici ça va être un succès
en fait c'est un peu un miracle nous ont
dit que c'est un miracle parce que
c'était un petit film c'est une histoire
très humaine il n'y a pas de meurtre pas
d'accident de voiture
j'ai très peu utile quoi
est ce que vous pouvez nous il raconté
le sujet du film parce que finalement
ici très peu de journaux
[Musique]
histoire d'un voyage c'est un couple de
bavarois pas très heureux je pense en
fait leur union est plutôt triste
peut-être que c'est elle qui avait envie
d'aller en amérique
je crois que ça se voit sa coiffure qui
n'a rien de très bas varois le
revêtement par contre sont typiquement
bavarois est peut-être que c'est elle
qui a voulu lui serait plutôt aller en
italie comme tous
peut-être que c'était une fuite d'une
certaine manière mais elle n'en est pas
vraiment sûr mais si vous faites
vraiment un voyage dans le désert en
allant de las vegas arrête panneaux ce
prix
et que vous ne vous entendez pas bien
vous êtes vraiment perdu dans votre
voiture parce que vous êtes toujours
ensemble
c'était vraiment comme je les vis une
situation très triste il ne s'aime
vraiment pas tous les deux alors un
moment elle décide de partir et c'est
vraiment un moment spécial parce que ça
se passe dans le désert alors elle parle
avec leurs bagages
avec ses bagages à lui aussi
[Musique]
est là elle arrive dans une station
d'essence lien un café
elle décide de partir et elle voit un
signe dans le ciel dans un sens c'est
les catholiques aussi et elle croit
qu'il ya un signe dans le ciel et elle
décide bon je pars par là et alors elle
arrive à une station d'essence qui
s'appelle bagdad le café bagdad et alors
elle rencontre brenda
il ya aussi la famille de cette femme
noire est une noire
oui alyn ware est aussi un vieux type
clé joué par jack palance qui dit qu'il
était à hollywood avant et le fils de
brenda qui passe son temps à jouer du
jean sébastien bach
[Musique]
mc
oui c'est très étonnant il ya aussi la
fille et le mari ils méritent un peu en
retrait
ils regardent
ils étaient sur le point de partir il
devait partir et c'est très drôle parce
qu'elle est très triste elle est assise
sur une chaise et elle regarde et elle
se demande qu'est ce que c'est un oiseau
ou quoi et en fait c'est moi
j'arrive et je décide de répondre à un
certain temps je ne peux pas partir je
ne peux pas revenir sur mes pas elles
font que jaurès je dois penser à mon
avenir au début vous accepte pas très
bien non fissile après ça va mieux quoi
je sais j'essaye est une partie de moi
même dit ne part pas et j'essaye de
devenir ami avec elle et c'est possible
car je tombe amoureuse des enfants ses
enfants ce petit bébé
j'essaie de rester là peut-être qu'en
bavière j'ai aussi une station d'essence
c'est le genre de choses que je connais
et j'essaie de m'installer là
une boîte une boîte de magie
oui mais elle n'était pas dans ma valise
peut-être que c'est mon mari qui l'a
achetée à las vegas et vous commencez à
faire des tours de manège oui et ça
devient une attraction dans le café
ça a beaucoup de succès et ensuite vous
n'avez plus droit de rester aux états
unis
parce que je n'ai pas de carte de
travail et vous êtes obligé de partir
et là il ya une scène très très belle si
lorsque vous revenez on s'imagine que
vous êtes retourné en bavière que vous
avez obtenu un visa peut-être même un
certificat de travail
peut-être même que j'ai divorcé
peut-être on ne sait pas vraiment toi
ces fourmis c'est très très politique
ça me plaît beaucoup aussi parce que des
fois les gens disent c'est très
harmonieux trop bas
vive dans le désert n'est pas toujours
si harmonieuse parce que la nature est
assez dur là-bas et les gens aussi et
moi quand j'étais là-bas j'ai trouvé que
les heures passaient très lentement
je me suis dit que c'était une décision
formidable qu'elle avait prise de vivre
cette wilaya
les camions qui passent jour et nuit qui
s'arrêtent de temps en temps qui
s'arrête de plus en plus souvent quand
vous faites vos tours de magie avec
brenda et que vous commencez à mettre au
point un vrai numéro comme sur une scène
oui ça ça m'a beaucoup plu parce que
j'étais obligé de vraiment apprendre des
tours justement je vais vous demander si
vous avez appris où c'était du cinéma
non non on le voit bien parce qu'il n'ya
pas de coupes dans les deux premières
scènes
les autres scènes ne pouvait pas être
aussi longue parce que ce n'était pas
seulement un film sur la machine mais
les deux premières scènes
vous avez été obligé d'apprendre du tour
de magie oui c'était difficile alors il
ya jack adams qui habite dans une
caravane
lucky qui fait plein de tableaux de vous
comme ça
seul aime beaucoup vous savez c'est
vraiment jake allen je les ai vus jouer
pendant des années des rôles de dur de
méchants et je crois que ça maintenant
c'est vraiment lui c'est pas un match où
il a un visage très dur de grands pieds
une voix très forte mais les si sensible
il peut se mettre en colère vraiment il
n'est pas typiquement américain p je les
aime beaucoup
allez
[Musique]
en gros
alors hassani hdidou avec catherine
barma quand on a vu le petit article sur
toi dans actuelle ce mois ci on a eu
tous les deux sans se concerter envie
d'inviter et puis maintenant qu'on voit
ce que tu fermes et ravi de t'avoir
invité alors tu tu sors d'où nous mon
plaisir de montpellier avant du manque
montpellier dijoux d'accord on voit ce
que tu fais on espère que le pen n'a pas
gagné les élections ce serait
qu'on voit plus que tu fais est vrai
montré quand même alors comment ça s'est
passé comment tu t'es lancé l'amenant
vous donner envie de faire mais moi tes
trucs afin d'acheter du cuir est habillé
les copies et puis way to très sympa ça
a été précis l'année dernière puisque
j'ai présenté un dossier pour faire
partie de la biennale
des jeunes créateurs à barcelone ouais
je me suis fait connaître et
voilà c'est à ce moment là bas c'était
un peu dur mais ça s'est très très bien
ouais j'aime apporter de l'aide et
madame j'ai décidé catalan elle était
très très pudiquement aller à la plage
et mettez le haut et le bas des
dimensions comme ça
un peu emmerdé qu'elle est portée parce
qu'il avait des marques de maillots
c'était infernal puis ils ont porté en
fait des jupes
ce que je fais des vêtements aussi
et après j'étais en colère et donc j'ai
organisé un défilé dans une boîte où il
y avait les concerts de rock qui passait
en même temps qu'à trouver des gens pour
défiler pour toi et d'usa eu de la
chance vous a désigné jean déjà passé et
maintenant alors comment tu comment tu
prends maintenant ça va mieux que j'ai
déjà des défilés qui sont prévus à
l'avancé les gens ça ce que je vais
présenter c'est à moi de trouver des
modèles parce que là s'était imposé à
barcelone là où j'avais pas vraiment
choisi au début et voilà je me prends à
ganges c'est vrai que c'est ouais enfin
pour l'instant
tous les oignons en eau pour faire tout
ça je je travaille par si je trahis par
là enfin je fais des petits jobs et puis
les quais un peu de sous
s'il en est les filles qui présente ses
les oblige à toi bah ouais oh oui
maintenant mais
pour les mecs à faire des trucs ouais
quoi des trucs comme ça ouais
pourquoi pas pareil non pas tant et fais
pas adapté ouais mais adapté quand même
pour garçon
s'est déjà essayé d'en faire porter à
des vagues des trucs comme ça ils sont
d'accord il ya un mec qui a défilé pour
moi c'est lui qui s'est proposé les mecs
vous rendez développe un projet même
s'ils sont pas les idées toutes faites
et c'est comme ça ça peut arriver
tiendra bon soir commande vient ton
pierre grimblat
ses chances elle y parle ou
pierre d'accord mais grimblat pourquoi
exemple alors parce que grave la danse
était grue de l'acte mes parents à
bedous autrichien bataille feuilles
vertes après voilà et puis donc comme je
suis de verdi jeune homme prometteur
plus l'effet de la radio très vite les
18 ans celle du grain de la passion au
bout de plâtre les ensembles et pinceaux
ouais voilà c'était c'était après la
guerre on pouvait quand même s'appeler
longue date au plombier est légalement
et en toute sécurité
sauf que vous pourriez vous avez jamais
vus
comment ça commence et tout ça ça fait
des émissions de télé et de radio
devrait finalement été directement à la
radio à sec j'ai fait avant première un
botté ouais ça consiste en quoi ça vous
intéresse que tu fais ce soir bon poids
savons
ce qui est marrant c'est que tu as
commencé par la télé après tu as fais de
la radio et puis en effet après de la
pub sur celle inverse de moi quoi c'est
ça ouais et sérieuse de toi comme
maintenant bah ouais dites le avec des
fleurs tu as dit que quand on aura vu ce
film on pourra plus jamais regardé des
fleurs après non plus jamais en tout cas
pas en forme de couronne funéraire ça
aurait été le cas et ce qui a fait que
je me suis enterré sous les fleurs ou
question et que j'ai plus fait ce film
de cinéma j'ai dû me suis dit voilà le
pic du cinéma ne mérite pas il ne mérite
pas des films ouais je le prive de bois
dur dur je la paie une décision due pour
le
g us le vent quand même qui a bien
marché we dance et truffaut qui m'a dit
j'aurais dû faire que je dois vie parce
que je vais avoir une histoire et une
petite fille
j'ai cherché depuis il a semblé trouver
en angleterre il visait de labeur qui
gérait les bagnes a réussi que j'ai
menées en france et j'avais engagé pour
jouer son rôle avec encore plus moche
que moi qui étais gainsbourg
j'ai présenté puis et 2 et gainsbourg va
déjà pas prendre cet âne à l'arc parce
qu'ils vont tenir que la fille que je
vais contacter c'était marisa berenson
way à l'époque six grands médias du
monde ce qui faisait vachement bien
serge de jouer avec une fille
et quand il ya bieber qui nivelle coop
en os mais les poubelles qui ne pleurait
sur l'arête bio faiblesse paris ce mec
mais sinon il était sincère il renchéri
john elway ce que j'ai fait à la fin de
première série de tours elle redit que
ses larmes le maire jean j'aurai des
coûts des enfants peut pas rester comme
ça ce soir on dit tous les trois chez
maxi j'ai retenu de table chez maxis à
vendredi soir et je suis pas allé à et
le lundi 29 à paris le tournage tout
allait bien cet effet un siège par an
pour ses additions salle où il doit
toujours tout le pognon tag avait gagné
avec slogans thürler perdu avec avec des
robes day des fleurs et bien vous
suiviez ben voilà le but de la
télévision lui il à savoir peut
comprendre et je suis arrivé à la télé
j'ai dit au public
prendre un bébé
après une série noire serrer sa vraie
série noire qui marche toujours mais je
vais bientôt arrêter jeu pourquoi petits
cailloux
j'ai fait série noire devrait tomber 40
avec 35 donner du travail à tous les
réalisateurs tous les acteurs de nanars
l'europe et 0,2 aux états unis godard
l'a fait
je veux dire assez de godard à jet hiver
des plus populaires aux plus difficiles
serieslive entendent entier y compris
aux états unis ensuite j'ai fait la thur
passant j'ai fait leur sinon je fais
toujours et
j'arrête c'est rare
à la fin de l'année parce que va débuter
attendez-vous bien attention c'est un
scoop je vais vous dire je ne sais pas
dit parce que c'est lui c'est le soir
quand on
s'est parlé on regarde du grand bal ce
parent d'élève
si karim aga corps oui je sais c'est
bien quand écoutiez voilà je vais faire
sur la seule trait à la rentrée la série
policière avec le plus d'actions toutes
les semaines plus de tension de la
violence de sexe l'ultra violent ça va
s'appeler les prairies haute tension
vous vous précipitez pourvoir aux
tensions sur la salle les pays
organisateurs les stars les plus
pulpeuse les plus biscotte un
ça va être haute tension croyez moi les
gars y aura pour son argent fait pas
perdu son temps la pub remarque un bon
c'est vrai il a appris avant j'ai un
truc quand je vais à bille sur la télé
je la vends je veux que si un seul mec
décroche donc j'ai pendant trop
d'émissions sur l'antenne je me flingue
du combat et oblige qu'est ce tu fais
tout ton pognon
pognon badri la vie est vive en gros tu
veux ma paie des bijoux un est la même
elle a même un petit rigolo mais
attention
je suis aidé à corriger les fans de foot
beaucoup d'argent mais à part ça qu'est
ce tu fais ta rembourser tout est d'être
là quand même à pratiquement c'est quoi
les dettes s'était toujours dit l'ex des
fleurs quitter l'urss elle commencé a
perdu combien a coûté à faire des
chevaux s'évacue les de l'impôt chat -
pour les pdg fait la bêtise ne pas
déclarer appsteur faillite puis de dire
je suis là les enfants jouent perret
skoda news où j'en arrive au 10 mai
voilà non mais quand même sur 20 repas
par an fait une
vraie carrière de réalisateur et que
j'étais bien trop dit oui à la mairie la
vie commence à nous entend oui c'est
maintenant que hamster est devenue la
plus importante la meilleure maison de
télévision en france que je vois pour un
tout petit bout de champ et faire défi
des films d'art et d'essai en 16 mm non
pas du tout mon pote sinon je sais pas
c'est pas ce dont j'ai envie d'être
reconnu je suis j'ai recueilli
joly d'être reconnu par commandé par mes
pairs et même mes compères j'ai envie
que les gens disent merde sept types qui
avait toujours là de saint-jean-de-luz
en mai il avait là vraiment un très très
très très local en voilà ce que je vais
faut dix délégués important que nous
avons tous comme chapier
[Musique]
elle quitte le privilège pour le
bataclan 28 29 30 avril clémentine
célarié en passant dans les bains
[Musique]
pour
oh
et vous
où
[Musique]
c'est vrai que
nous
[Musique]
c
et
[Musique]
vite
tu vois
c'est
en
[Musique]
promis qui
m
[Musique]
non
pour toi
o o
[Musique]
non
et
m
[Musique]
lors du même mois
comment
[Musique]
voilà
à
[Musique]
bon
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
leonard itunes abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus